يوم ان هادئ في البيت الابيض لكنه ينظر
بعاصفه سياسيه فمشاكل الرئيس بيدن
القانونيه تتراكم بعد الكشف عن وثائق سريه
جديده في بيته ليصل مجموعه الوثائق الى 20
وثيقه بعض المحامين المحافظين يرون بان
بيض في خطر اكبر من الرئيس ترامب الذي
احتفظ بحوالي 300 وثيقه في منتجعه في
مارالرجو ورفض التعاون مع المحققين
والمحامين والتهمه بعرقله مشرع العداله
والسبب ان ترامب انه نزع السريه عن تلك
الوثائق امر يخوله الدستور حسب بعض
المحامين المحافظين لكن هناك انقسام في
وجهه النظر القانونيه التي تقول بان هذه
الصلاحيه هي من صلاحيات الكونجرس وليس
الرئيس ومهما كابرا او ثوره حجم الخطر
فهناك موسى الى ق وشيكا في مجلس النواب
وهذا قد يؤثر على فرص الرئيس في الترشح
لولايه